- [Instructor] In this video,
we're going to talk about
how people can interact with, influence,
and participate in society.
When you do so, you're
participating in civic life,
which is distinct from your private life.
Private life includes all the
ways that you pursue happiness
through relationships,
hobbies, or your job,
that is, if you're not
a member of government.
Civic life includes all the
ways that you might take part
in solving the problems of your community,
whether that's by
volunteering in civil society,
making rules or laws, or
serving in a government body,
whether that's the school
council or the U.S. Senate.
So if you like playing video games,
playing for fun is part
of your private life.
But if you joined a group petitioning
for more representation
of diverse characters in video games,
you'd be entering into civic life.
Then you're not just doing things
that make you happy individually.
You're striving to have an
effect on the lives of others.
So when you step into civic life,
you will become involved
with politics and government.
Although you often hear
them lumped together,
they're not actually the same thing.
You could say that politics is something
that you do, an action.
Politics encompasses all the ways
that people reach agreements in a group,
by negotiating, compromising, or voting.
And those people might
not agree with each other,
but through the political process,
they agree to be bound by the rules
that they've negotiated together.
So in the large scale,
politics describes both
how Congress debates bills
and how you and your brother
decide who does the dishes.
Then there's government.
Government is a noun,
and it describes both the institutions
like the Supreme Court or the city council
which make and enforce laws,
as well as the people who
serve in those institutions.
So government could describe both FIFA,
the international
governing body for soccer,
as well as the referee whose
job it is to enforce the rules
that soccer teams and
players agree to abide by.
Okay, so now that you've
learned about civic life,
private life, politics, and
government, here's a pop quiz.
I'm gonna give you a few scenarios,
and you see if you can match
them to the correct term.
First up, Ayla's church
provides food and shelter
for the homeless community
during the winter
to keep them out of the cold.
Is this an example of
civic life, private life,
politics, or government?
Pause the video here
and see what you think.
If you guessed civic life, you're correct.
Ayla is participating in what
we call civil society here,
which you might remember
from another video.
Civil society includes all
of the voluntary institutions
that people form and join
outside of government and the market.
She's doing something for her community.
Okay, next.
The Supreme Court hears a case
about internet copyright
law and the First Amendment.
Is this an example of
civic life, private life,
politics, or government?
This is government.
The Supreme Court is
part of a governing body
that enforces the rules.
Okay, last one.
Jeffrey, a representative for the AARP,
reaches out to Senator Rodriguez
to provide more information
on the impact a bill making its way
through the House will
have on senior citizens.
He wants to secure Senator
Rodriguez's support
when the bill reaches the Senate.
Is this an example of
civic life, private life,
politics, or government?
If you guessed politics, you're right.
Jeffrey is providing information,
hoping to influence a decision
that will affect others.
Okay, thanks for playing.
Keep practicing your skills in
the exercise for this lesson.